foreign
months after we got married she had
accused me of abuse was it all
fabricated it was she was hitting me and
everything I held down her arms to stop
her from hitting me one of her
therapists all the you know the markings
on her arms so they reported that and
that led off to a whole you know a
year-long investigation
[Music]
what in the world is going on this is
John with the Dr John deloney's show and
man I'm so glad that you are with us
hanging out trying to figure out
Our dating relationships our marriage
our mental health and our emotional
health our kids whatever is going on in
the world
on this show we talked to real people
going through real hard stuff and we try
to figure out what to do
next if you want to be on the show give
me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 that's
1-844-693-3291 Kelly you're looking at
me what did I do I do something
no I'm sorry I I it was you never make
direct eye contact like that unless I'm
in trouble I looked up there you were it
was an accident
but did you notice that it was today it
was an accident today's callers did you
notice a theme
it's an all-time show yeah it is
Yeehaw way to go America
look at that way to go Texas
right now my family's all in Texas and
it's a 111 degrees
I don't know if you all know this who
are listening to the show who don't live
in Texas but in Texas they actually
teach you in the Bible that um hell is
really cold
because hot just doesn't bother anybody
anymore
anyway if you didn't know that now you
know and as the great GI Joe said
knowing is half the battle all right
let's go out to San Antonio the greatest
food in America and talk to Zach what's
up Zach
hello Dr John how we doing
I'm living the dream
anybody who says I'm living the dream is
never living the dream what's up dude I
I got to apologize I'm not an original
text and I just moved here so oh no
where'd you move from
uh Hawaii uh we'll take you for sure
okay yeah dude uh are you are you uh
originally from Hawaii
no uh I was in the Navies I moved around
a lot so actually I grew grew up mostly
on the west coast different states uh so
you came to be converted huh yep well
congratulations man never too late never
too late welcome to the to the Lone Star
State and I just rhymed so I'm a rapper
too what's up man
uh well you know I know I sent you an
email and um it sounded really Doom and
Gloom um I didn't get it I don't uh they
don't give those to me Jenna just gets
them so we have to have a we can have a
natural conversation so tell me about it
okay
well you know I had originally asked you
know how do I just find the will to move
on you know just just so many layers to
this onion that I try to narrow down my
question to you know for your show and a
lot of it you know just kind of revolves
around my second ex-wife
um okay
so the back story on that is
um I was originally married back in 2017
and the marriage lasts about maybe a
year and a half and um it was a very
rough marriage
um I was able to escape that marriage
and after I dug out of prison I went
back to the front door and allowed her
back into my life and I'm just starting
to regret that so are you all still
together
uh yes it's uh I don't know how much
time you have I can tell you the full
story go for it man
um so when I got married in 2017 it was
after a year of dating um
shortly maybe like four months after we
got married she had accused me of abuse
yeah I doubt so
no
sir you're good man take a breath take a
breath dude you're all good
so you know after four months you know
just really affected me was it totally
was it all fabricated
it was um it was just I think because
to give a little you know
you know a little context there you know
she's just
um an irrational person or just really
insecure some bipolar and they're just
you know a little dash of Tourette's
right
and um so
she you know she was hitting me and
everything so I held down her arms to
stop her from hitting me like then I
think I guess one of her therapists saw
the you know the markings on her arms so
they reported that
and um and that led off to a whole you
know a year-long investigation and then
mandatory counseling
and so on and uh were you charged
criminally
no I wasn't I mean and well because in
the military I mean you're guilty until
proven guilty right so it doesn't matter
if you're if you're found you know not
guilty uh because it's never about that
just about you know making sure that
spouses safe and the member is safe did
you get court-martialed
uh no I did go uh get um what we call
non-judicial punishment and uh it wasn't
related to
the actual abuse it was related for me
violating uh a order given by my
commanding officer
um and that was just in order for not to
talk to the spouse
um and then
uh so for you know for the entire year
and a half that we were married I was
actually not living at home for a good
year and I had to have my own place I
was paying for two places at the time in
Hawaii of all places yeah it's expensive
um so bring me up to right now you you
got cleared of everything you did your
non-traditional punishment you learned
whatever lessons you need to learn
what are you yeah what are you doing
so you know in order well so after the
year and a half that we were married
I had divorced her and
she refused to leave so she became a
squatter in my house and so for three
years after that
I lived with her living there she just
refused to believe that we were divorced
refused to believe that there was no
relationship why didn't you call the
police sack
ideas and the police says there's
nothing they can do
um this was even after an episode where
she got insanely crazy how do I hate to
use a term but then I had locked myself
in the spare room and she kicked the
door in broke it literally in half and I
called the cops and cops said well
there's nothing they can do because she
lives there and I was like well because
this was the other way around I think
cops are ready of course but yeah so I I
it must just be difference in how
Hawaii's laws work but if you're
divorced if you've got divorce papers
juggle through the proceedings
everything was finalized yeah I mean so
Hawaii has a rule where you know you
serve the papers and they don't respond
within 20 days you'd be a divorced by
default correct and so I mean I did that
um
so I had I you know did this whole
year-long plan I was gonna convince her
that we're all moving to Texas together
and then I had to sell my house I put on
the plane as soon as her parents and I
moved to Texas you know because I told I
had to stay behind her to finish some
work stuff
and when I got to Texas I um
um
you know I didn't have anybody here it
was just me and um I was certainly you
know lonely and everything so started
talking with her again then
um we had agreed that you know we're
going to try this out again if she comes
back we're gonna try it out if it
doesn't work out she's gonna go back
home okay bring me to bring me to right
now man bring me to right now
um it just right now
um she had another she back living with
you again she is back living with me and
I told her she had to leave but she just
yeah that you can't possibly think that
she's gonna leave
yeah she's not and of course not she
never has there's nothing I can do to
get her to leave because I even called
her parents parents can't do anything
you know uh
you can call the police and you can in
Texas and I know this
you can call the sheriff's department in
Texas and say I have broken up with my
girlfriend
and she refuses to leave my property of
which she has zero claim
okay we are divorced she needs to go
and she is refusing to leave I need
assistance
okay okay had that exact conversation
and now listen
none of this matters if three months
from now you call her back and invite
her back over
yeah I'm just
yeah it was it was really stupid okay I
just you know I mean I just like really
living the same traumas for the past
five years I was just living in flight
mode and just I I got you I got you but
bro you I mean
did you learn your lesson now I mean you
got you got bit
by a rattlesnake for three years and
then you get to Texas and you're like
I'm gonna put my hand back in that bag
and get bit again yeah that's exactly
what I did and just
yeah and she's clearly struggling she's
got a lot going on that you can't solve
but man you can protect yourself and
keep you safe right
yeah and it's it's just yeah I
understand it just I I'm afraid to do
anything because if I say anything it's
gonna just
open up a whole can of worms where
here's the thing Zach I would I would
record I would record our conversations
I would call the sheriff's department
today
and I would make as clean and as quick a
break as possible while also treating
her with dignity and respect you brought
a person who's not well
back into your life into a situation
where they have faltered before
okay and so she's not well
she's not stable and she makes things
very hard she makes up stories she put
you through year of proceeding she
wouldn't leave your house she wouldn't
she doesn't acknowledge reality fine I'm
gonna give her the benefit of the doubt
and just assume that she is very very
sick
but you
put her back in a situation where she
has never been successful in the past
and so you've got to own your part of
this and that means getting well and
getting healthy means owning the
transition out of this mess
there is no possible way this happens
cleanly
or or without it it can happen cleanly
it doesn't happen without chaos without
accusations without I'm not leaving
without somebody getting arrested
without there is no go ye gentle into
that good night that will not happen
here
just know that just know that
but I'm gonna treat her with dignity and
respect
I've asked her to leave she won't leave
I'm going to call the sheriff in Texas
and I'm going to ask for assistance
removing somebody a former roommate from
my home because they will not leave
and um they should come help you out
and if they don't then it's time to get
a lawyer
and a lawyer will you will hire them to
work on your behalf but but it's it's
time it's time it's time and then you my
brother are gonna have to do the hard
hard work
of making Community there in San Antonio
because you can't live in isolation you
can't live by yourself and you can't
continue to call people who are not well
to come in and try to try to
be that Band-Aid for you while you're
hurting man sorry you're going through
this my brother I wish you all the best
in the future
um
be very clear
ask for help receive help and then for
God's sake man create an accountability
plan so you don't find yourself in these
exact same situations again in the
future thanks for calling my brother
we'll be right back
[Music]
this show is sponsored by better help
folks take a minute to think about how
much time you spend on yourself it's
easy to get caught up in what people
need from you and want from you and
never think about what you need and then
you end up too stretched out burned out
all of the madness of our current world
resting on your shoulders
look sometimes I put my head down to
work and then realize I haven't had a
meaningful conversation with my wife and
kids all day I get focused on what I'm
doing and I'm running and running and
running
and I don't know how to come back
and therapy is a great way to learn new
skills that make you the best version of
yourself they help you set boundaries
and still have energy left to help
others without leaving yourself behind
so if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try it's
totally online to fit into your schedule
you just fill out a brief questionnaire
to get matched with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists at any
time for no additional charge so find
more balance find Wellness with better
help visit betterhelp.com deloney today
to get 10 off your first month that's a
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right let's go back to the Lone Star
State on the right side of DFW in Fort
Worth and talked to Ashley what's up
Ashley
well I didn't grow up in Texas but I got
here as soon as I could that a girl way
to go way to go what's up
um my husband and I were not on the same
page about kids anymore so I wrote in
with my questions
how do I cope with emotions of fear and
anxiety that my husband will not agree
to adopt our foster baby
do you know do you know for certain he's
not going to adopt this baby
well I've I've always felt that his do
you know
I don't know for certain I think he's
more of a maybe I think he's
um he can be convinced and maybe more
time and bonding will change his tune
but I feel a sense of guilt because
I'll change him I will change him
no woman has ever thought that about a
man ever
exactly no I sound crazy and no man has
ever been like no I for sure like told
you whatever the thing is
and I'll change him
so here's I I know I'm sorry I'm
interrupting you you're making me you're
making me laugh because hey you're
awesome MB I know your heart is good and
see oh boy right
um
anytime somebody tells me they're
anxious about a potential outcome I
always
and I always want to default to a very
simple yet devastating statement okay
okay it's just a few words facts are
your friend
so before you get anxious before you get
worked up before you start creating
these narratives about what about this
what about this and I'm gonna try this
I'm scheming you're coming up with all
these blueprints
about sitting down with him and saying I
need to know right now
will you be willing to adopt this baby
I'm almost afraid to keep bringing it up
I know okay let's uh why is it because
you're afraid of being devastated and
having to be married to a man that won't
see this through with you or are you
devastated because you know I can't stay
in this relationship if this is actually
true
oh he's we're going to stay in the
relationship I I know that my marriage
is the first priority and I did go into
this Foster experience expecting
having foster children that would be
reunified and we just didn't expect to
get a week old baby
that probably will not be reunified with
biological parents and probably will be
available for adoption and
it's just I'm in love with this baby and
my husband's like not his intention is
not to adopt he just says
you know you're doing a bait and switch
I was gonna Foster we were going to
Foster only you know but my heart has
changed
um have you said that exact word that
exact phrase
no that's the phrase that needs to be
spoken because bait and switch is an
accusation that you lied to me in order
to you tricked me that's very different
than my heart my heart has changed
I held a little baby and everything's
different now
so here's a good example in my house
this is not for everybody this is just
for me okay my wife was a stone cold she
still is but back when we were younger
she was a gangster professional she's
one of the best teachers I've ever seen
in my life ever and I've worked
alongside teachers my whole career and
then when she transitioned to become a
professor she was unbelievable as a
professor as a researcher and all that
and we she made good money I made good
money so together we had a good combined
income and so when it came to like
buying houses and she got pregnant like
we need to get a house and all this I
said I want to wait
until we until you hold that baby
because I want our household to be free
for you to go whoa forget all of this
work stuff I'm staying here
and that didn't happen initially right
but but listen I waited for that because
I didn't it wasn't going to be a baton
switch I wanted to honor her heart
wherever that went and I didn't want to
be as tied to a stupid mortgage I'd much
rather rent and be in peace right so for
you it's not a bait and switch it's no
we're gonna Foster we're gonna Foster
we're gonna Foster
holy smokes this baby is mine
it's different right
but you you though have to speak up and
be heard even though the risk is he may
look at you and say I don't care no
he's showing a little bit more
favor now you're baiting is switching
him
you see now you're starting to try to
play games so that he'll want to keep
this kid
don't do that don't do that yeah I don't
want to manipulate him there you go and
you're starting to be like well he's
really quiet I'm gonna go hand him to
him right now
and yeah I'm gonna yeah don't do that
okay so just describe to him how my
feelings have changed because I used to
not want kids either
but it's like after I turned 35 it's
just something just I feel like it's
changing in me sure and listen I I think
the um
hello
you were really honoring how he feels
and you're really honoring his original
commitment which is I don't want kids
what you're not doing is honoring how
you feel on an equal playing field and
you deserve to be honored in the exact
same way
and so in the same way that he is making
his feelings very clear to you
you have a right
as a co-creator of that household
State out loud my heart has changed
and I I didn't want kids forever and
then I held this baby
it's different now and you and him are
then going to have to make a decision
on what what look moving forward looks
like
and that probably won't be fun and that
probably won't be pleasant or it might
be wonderful who knows
who knows
be more open to the idea because
he doesn't want me to quit my job I'm
not even approaching that yet but is
that is that is that in your soul like
if he came to you tonight and said hey
I've been thinking I want to adopt this
baby I want you to stay at home I want
you to be a full-time stay-at-home mom
and take care of this kid would that
give you would that lift your spirits
oh I'd love that I'm feeling like so
stressed because because I'm not giving
a great performance at work and trying
to do both and my mind's focused on this
three-month-old baby and my husband's
feelings
so yeah I just couldn't even care about
work anymore do you hear who just got
buried there
my work sucks I gotta take care of this
baby and I gotta take care of my husband
you're right so I'm gonna take me and
put her in a concrete box and bury her
in the backyard until this whole thing
blows over at age 18 and that's when
couples wake up and realize I don't know
you anymore
[Music]
the only path forward is honesty and
vulnerability and the sucky thing about
honesty and vulnerability is you can get
really really hurt
because you can say my heart changed and
he can say I don't care
and now what was an issue about being
parents is now an issue of I am married
to a man that thinks so little of my
heart changing that I'm frozen forever
you all have to deal with that
the same way that he's gonna have to
deal with
my wife made some Ironclad commitments
to me and her heart changed no fault of
her own but it changed and so what else
has changed what else might change in
the future right it's unnerving too
that's true
but not saying those things out loud as
a couple
dude
Secrets destroy relationships
yeah but it is the fear that has been
making it swirl in my head and not come
out in conversation so that's right I
hear you it's the honesty it is
I need to be more direct and honest and
usually one of of two things help our
play here
that you've been spending so much time
in other people's heads and you have
experienced your first
couple of months of life with a with a
infant and so you're so sleep deprived
that it's just hard to kind of filter
reality a little bit or
you know exactly what's going to happen
to your relationship if you are totally
vulnerable and honest
he's not going to
depart I I do feel off-kilter
um like this baby brain feeling of
confusion sometimes but
um I I do believe he's there for me and
um I just need to take that leap of
faith okay
oh
yes remember
all relationship is a risk
all of it
you can be married two months you can be
dating two weeks you can be married 70
years
always a risk when you go all in and
tell the truth
with your spouse with your kids with
your employer all relationship is a risk
it's hard scary
and so we're not we're not we're not
having this conversation so that you can
trick him or convince him
this conversation is so that you can put
all your cards on the table you can open
your hands up and say I'm being fully
present I'm being here
and this is my heart's changed I love
that I love that the sentiment of that I
love that statement my heart's changed
that's a powerful powerful statement
I'm different now
and I'm hoping you'll come on this
adventure with me
and possibly even be honest and then say
I know this is a lot and so let's
reconvene in a week let's reconvene in
10 days I'm gonna do it all right now
because I'll give you some time to
process and think through it
um
but there's no bait and switch here I
didn't trick you
my heart changed things are different
now
[Music]
and as somebody who's co-creating a life
with each other with you
you got to know all of it
start there
let us know how that conversation goes
and we'll be thinking about you it's a
tough one tough one tough one and by the
way thank you for being somebody who
Fosters little babies
[Music]
those are the on you are the unsung
heroes of our communities and our
neighborhoods and our states and our
country
amazing amazing we'll be right back
hey what's up deloney here it's that
time of year where a lot of us are
traveling again I mean I've been
traveling flying driving living out of
hotels and that's all fun and good for a
while except when you're camping whoa
but it can all get so exhausting and you
know this as well as I do can wreck your
sleep that's why there's nothing like
coming home to your own bed especially
when you've got a world-class mattress
like a dream Cloud dream Cloud
mattresses will make an incredible
difference in the quality and depth of
your sleep which is an absolute Game
Changer especially when you're traveling
all over creation right now dream cloud
is offering their biggest deal ever
exclusively for our listeners 40 off of
all mattresses plus an additional fifty
dollars in savings listen if you're not
excited to come home to your own bed
it's time to make a change visit
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
John deloney to get your new mattress
today that's dreamcloudsleep.com
and enter promo code John deloney
all right we are back let's go out to
where my parents live in Abilene Texas
and talk to Tracy what's up Tracy
hey
we're hot here
Tracy is this Tracy Tracy this is Tracy
Tracy oh my God
Tracy Tracy Tracy
how in the world are you I'm doing great
how are you
you've known me for a long time and I'm
I'm speechless right now
I'm excited
[Laughter]
oh man all right so for people the rest
of y'all listening
um
Tracy how would you classify
Tracy ran my life
for years
um and Tracy was had a like on this show
in in just in books and where I've
talked about just
um melting down like uh being doubled
over with anxiety and just really
melting and having to figure my way back
out Tracy had a ringside seat to that
you watched it real close up and Tracy
is one of the people that I credit with
being the tether that kept me held to
reality when things got real thin and
scary so I could tell with your voice
Tracy
good gracious it's so good to hear from
you
oh man
what have you done
what are you up to
well I just um had a hard day the other
day and I said I'm gonna just write all
this down and see if I can get some help
and then I got a call so I was like oh
that's different than I expected
well number one thank you for
um reaching out and two you can always
just call my cell phone you're on the
you're in my inner circle you're in my
super Inner Circle uh yeah I'm only here
because you were in my life and made
sure I was fed and watered for a couple
of years so all right so uh what's going
on how can I help
have an adult
adult five if there's ten years
separation between her and her older
siblings
so she was a baby I knew she was going
to be my last child and I kind of ruined
her I spoiled the heck out of her
um which I enjoyed every second of it
and I had people telling me all the way
hey hey you're not doing the right thing
give me an example
what do you mean I never said no I just
figured there's a way we can make
everything
we can make everything happen we can
make everything work
she's super smart talented Charming
highly capable so I followed everything
went to everything encouraged everything
paid for everything whatever you need we
got it you know just
just everything
and so what happened recently that sets
you off well
it's like maybe
bail has been lifted from in front of me
and I'm seeing it a little different
um
she has a little bit of a tendency to
self-sabotage so she never really gets
to the success level so she can see what
that feels like or enjoy that which
always leaves are kind of in a mess
what does she get when she gets in a
mess
well some she quits her job or gets
fired no no underneath her what does she
get
I don't know attention maybe
I can think other than my wife and two
or three of my closest friends
this is just me talking to my friend
right now
I can think of a few oh crap Tracy I'm
gonna get all choked up I can think of
few people in the world
that have more have had more of a
positive impact in a one-on-one just
listening and making me feel like
everything was gonna be okay then you
you did that for me personally right at
about her same age right
and if that's what you get for getting
fired
I'd get fired every other week
I had to stay employed to get that with
you
me too yeah exactly that meant you had
to make sure both of us were still
employed so if that's what she gets if
she gets some special one-on-one time
with an extraordinary listener and an
extraordinary encourager an
extraordinary it's gonna be okay we're
gonna figure it out
then the
the like what I don't know why I would
need anything else everyone's pushing me
to get these other things that's what I
want because that's incredible
well and I love it I love spending the
time I love being the ear that listens
and the hug that Comforts I love doing
that
but things have kind of shifted a little
bit to being
um
no longer really
uh thankful or appreciative more like uh
kind of an O we owe it ah okay the
financial help the drop what you're
doing you know I'm coming I'm staying
stay up all night even though we have to
get up and go to work or you know just
things are just different and
I don't want to break down the barrier
of being the one that
is the safety net or the
comforting hug I don't want to break
that at all I just don't know the best
way to help
and still protect us
how's this affecting husband
uh he's he loves me and he says he'll do
whatever I want to do
but I'm sure you know if I'm feeling
some anxiety about it he's got to be
feeling some too
if it was just me and him having a drink
out there in West Texas what would he
tell me
right and he'd tell me that too I've
hung out with him so does the name Dr
Henry cloud ring a bell
I I don't think I know who Henry cloud
is okay him and a guy named John
Townsend wrote a book long ago called
Boundaries he's a psychologist and
um I'm gonna quote him because I love
the way he says it he says it real
direct and here's what he said
he said
in your situation what your daughter
needs more than anything in the world
she knows you love her and she knows you
will be there for her
but she needs more than anything if she
needs some problems
because the one person she doesn't know
will show up for her is her
because that person's never had to
and the way we get problems is we sit
down usually with our significant other
and we say okay we're going to implement
some boundaries here and it's going to
really be uncomfortable for everybody
and she'll kick and scream and say you
don't love me and you're leaving me out
to dry and I can't believe you abandoned
me and all that and you as a grown-up
will have to deal with how bad that
hurts because you know that's not true
and what you have to transition from now
is a it feels good right now it like it
feels really awesome this evening to
have her come home and hug and to make
dinner and to just listen to her because
she's hilarious
and think I'm aiming for a 35 year old
functional adult
right did his bringing their paid for a
car over to my my driveway
or they're they're driving me around in
their nice car that they paid for to
help me find a good retirement home for
me right
so
ultimately it's sitting down and saying
something along the lines of and I I
honestly at this at this stage at 27 I'd
put it in writing and that may be overly
dramatic which I have a flare for for
the over dramatic but I'd probably put
into writing like
you're always welcome at our house but
at midnight we lock the doors you can't
come in can't wake us up
from this point forward we don't we're
not giving you any more money outside of
X or Y or Z or here's five thousand
bucks and this is it
um
if you get fired from your job I will
sit in the back porch and I will
commiserate with you I'm not giving you
money I'm not making another call for
you you're gonna have to figure out what
happens next if you want to move into an
apartment you can move into an apartment
um
this may be a weird question when you
were young
did you get hung out to dry
um
not exactly
that's the most Tracy answer
did you have to figure things out at a
real young age oh yes very young
I think so how young
okay
do you remember that not being fun
or lonely or isolating or scary
I remember it being challenging
but now that I know myself I think I
like challenges but maybe I like
challenges because I figured things out
I don't know
but I don't remember hating it
I think that might be the greatest gift
you give her
it just is 12 years later then you got
it
so imagine a world where you say I love
you no more money
I love you you can't live here anymore
or you got you got three months you got
to find your own apartment you gotta
find your own place I don't even know if
she lived with you whatever but whatever
boundaries you draw
um
you got to pay your own car insurance
and your own cell phone bill you're 27
years old for crying out loud and you
can tell her I've already uh had to
babysit one other 27 year old years ago
named John and I'm not doing it again
I'll do it again
um
what happens after that
I don't know what happens how good
things happen I know down the road but
you have a picture of like that
conversation does she hear that well and
go you're right it's time for me to like
how would that conversation go
um she's probably gonna get mad and
storm away and I won't hear from her for
a while okay and then she slams the door
and walks out and your husband looks at
you walk me through what you would feel
right then because it's happened before
and I would cry but also
also she's not a child she doesn't need
our safety debt she needs to figure it
out on her own but it would still crush
me
what
um
what if I told you she doesn't get a
vote
does that sound like like gobbledygook
counseling nonsense
no that's why I called it doesn't sound
like nonsense
um so I had this experience right after
after
um
right after I moved out from moved from
the the city where we worked together
and I took my next job uh Hank I think
was still two and a half maybe maybe
three and
as long as I live I won't forget this
moment I walked in the front door and I
saw Hank in the in the in
the hallway little bitty kid
um and I said
come here Bubba and I I had my backpack
on and I crouched down to to be at eye
level with him and he looked at me and
he said no daddy and he took off running
down the hall and my first thought was
because you suck at being a dad
maybe if you were here and you weren't
taking more graduate classes after
you're already done with grad school and
maybe if you would just and I just
started I create this whole story
and I told Sheila and told my wife and
her first response was was
John the only game you play with him is
Chase
he's trying to that that's how he knew
how to connect with you
and that was the first like
oh man I missed it and then as I went
down that rabbit hole I got to thinking
why have I given my two and a half year
old a voice into how I feel
he's my kid he doesn't get to dictate
that my wife does two or three of my
closer friends do you in my life Tracy
did right like
will you get permission to speak into my
soul right like why would I give that to
my kid
my kids are emotional I'm their parent
right so it comes back to saying
practicing that oh you don't get a vote
if your husband tells you hey you're
being a terrible person well we need to
have that conversation if two or three
of your close friends tell you that we
need to have that conversation if your
kid tells you it hurts it stings
that you don't get a vote I'm moving
here I'm doing this right and I think
the magic word for me has been that's
something I have to practice it's just a
skill set I don't have
right
but it's gonna be awful I hate to tell
you that it won't be fun
I've been practicing it in my mind I
know
can you practice it in real life
I don't know
it seemed
a part of the game okay that's where I
would really challenge you I've got to
do it right
now I would challenge you and your
husband on that one I think setting it
up and going out to that Cracker Barrel
out there and saying here's what's gonna
happen now
because it takes it out of the immediacy
and we have to fire this thing off and
it's much more intentional and you own
you hold all the cards
you are setting up a breakfast you are
setting up the new boundaries you are
handing over a sheet of paper here's how
we're going to honor and love you and
you can say that we don't love you if we
don't give you everything you want but
this is going to be the new reality
because we have to let you fly on your
own you gotta learn how to do it
and so
um
that makes it less immediate and if if
she fires back with what about this what
about this what about this the response
has got to be that's a great that's a
great question I'll think about that
we'll holler back at you I'm not going
to give you a right answer right now
because that's not the point of this
conversation this conversation is to let
you know from this point forward here's
what the boundaries are going to look
like
it just takes that immediacy out of it
like that frantic oh I gotta do it right
now okay you can stay
and now we're like oh crap now you're
staying
or I'll give you a thousand bucks just
just don't do anything stupid
um it keeps it takes all that away
how's that sound
sounds okay hard yeah
how about this here's my promise
you think she'd call into the show after
you'll have that conversation and tell
me how much she hates me
I don't know
all right she right
probably not all right here's the deal
you text my private cell number after
the conversation
and if she throws a fit and goes
b-a-n-n-a-s
um
you can offer tell her John will talk to
you and
um I'd love to have her version on the
show too
okay
there's no chance she'll do that but
that would be awesome if she did Tracy
that would be awesome I would love to
hear the other side of it too because I
know there's two sides
I don't know I don't know about with you
you're one of the few good ones
so hey Before I Let You Go in front of
all these people they're listening
can I just tell you thank you for
being right or die with me when I was
falling apart
like for real absolutely I'm really
really grateful thank you for letting me
be there
oh come on duty-free are you for real I
told you that story about the time uh
we were having to make some really tough
budget cuts and included a lot of
personnel positions and one day we were
driving me and my wife and she goes oh
yeah hey John I can't believe I forgot
to tell you and I wrote turned the
window down I was like what and she goes
if you cut Tracy's position I'm leaving
you and I was like whoa I was like why
and she goes she looked at me and her
and she like moved her finger back and
forth and she's like because us we only
work because of her and I just remember
thinking
that's exactly right so on behalf of
everyone this show is being even
possible
who
thank you for being that stirring at the
end of my crazy balloon that was
floating off the outer space that kept
me Tethered to the ground
um and thank you for honoring Me by by
calling in on the show
um
you've got my cell number you call me
anytime day or night and um
I love you I'm so so grateful for you if
I can help it any other way holler back
at me we'll have you back on the show
and love to have your daughter on on the
show as well you guys are awesome we'll
be right back
[Music]
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible in each person's situation is
unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right as you wrap up today's show we
had to go with the Great and Powerful
Pat Green
shout out to my brother Aaron Watson but
we had to go with Pat Green here man
songs called girls from Texas on an all
Texas show
ing goes like this
girls from Georgia are sweeter than
peaches ones from California are made
for bathing suits and beaches well it's
gonna get me canceled
minutes
Minnesota gals look great in a sweater
but the girls from Texas are just a
little bit better
Mississippi's got them Delta queens and
Louisiana Cajun girls beat all I've ever
seen ever kiss a girl from Kansas you
sure won't forget her
the girls from Texas are just a little
bit better hell yeah we are
actually I've lied about all other
tattoos
Kelly does have this tattoo in Old
English across her back girls from Texas
are just a little bit better
whoa love you guys we'll see you soon
thank you
[Music]